was heißt da eigentlich ich weiß doch
dass sie jetzt schöne schwarze machen
für die heute show die ich mir auch
immer gerne angucke aber was heißt es
denn
[Musik]
hey hallo ich bin dein freund genosse
könnt ihr mich reinlassen ich bin einer
von euch ich bin jetzt mitglied hallo
die bei der ard ja freundlicher
[Musik]
ich würde mich mal interessieren was
heißt eigentlich was heißt da eigentlich
ich weiß doch dass sie jetzt schöne
schwarze machen für die heute show die
ich mir auch immer gerne an guckt ja
aber was heißt es denn ich darf ihnen
wirklich nicht antworten wenn ich vorher
nicht mal die übersetzung genau was sie
können
ich hab ja schon mal an gott ich muss
nicht jeden tag englisch ich gebe ihnen
noch eine chance 50 50 joker ich sage
ihnen zwei von vier buchstaben das c und
das trade agreement
diese können auch ihre schweren schritt
jetzt gehen wir rein oder ich bin ja
auch offiziell mitglied gut alles klar
ja war ganz einfach delegierten
natürlich nicht gut dann gucken sie
diese der vorne weiterkommen ich bin
genosse ja das ist mein parteibuch auch
handschriftlich eingetragen ist habe ich
von der königin der spd bekommen
hannelore kraft ich bin persönlicher
abgesandter
dankeschön ich bin auch dass sigmar
gabriel kürzlich die frage ist natürlich
wie kriegen wird trotzdem täter durch
die spd hat sich einen roten faden
gegeben ja es krieg haben das ist ein
schild weist ein schild oder eine rote
linie
diese ist nächstes ist er und schildert
ihren zettel
das ist kein farben und das ist schuldig
und der ist eigentlich ein symbolischer
fahren ist das erkämpft haben das ist
kein faden da muss ich leider kurz
anderen okay dann ist es ein
symbolischer verein
das ist ein zettel der symbolischen
formen und der haut sich genauso aber
dieser titel verstöße geht nicht so
einfach hier kinder kinder behütet in
der hohe berge sorge keine panik ich bin
von der spd
[Musik]
sigma sigma falls wir uns nicht mehr
wiedersehen alles gute liebe genossen
liebe presse nach heute ist eins klar
sigmar gabriel hat die partei komplett
erneuert aber wenn er bei der
bundestagswahl gescheitert ist solltet
ihr einst wissen
ich stehe bereit
[Applaus]
ich wollte euch nur um ein kleines auto
bieten
einfach anklicken macht's gut los hast
du scheiße fährt haye